we're back for part two of our worth of
Taiwan series today we're doing su
Taiwan's dial
it's amazing cuz it's so hot in Taiwan
and yet they love their soup here eaten
for breakfast lunch and dinner so many
great dishes to try but before we get
there
Stephen where are we we are here at the
jeans i chow hiyo pave salt fields
alright Inka you can guide you
historically one of the earliest salt
producing areas of Taiwan ocean water
comes in the Sun evaporates it you're
left with salt
speaking of salty liquids sweat no oh
we're doing soup today I'm worth it
we're gonna be trying three Taiwanese
soup set three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
most worth it at its price it's so windy
the typhoon just passed so we're having
a little bit north of the city of Tainan
to where income we're going to die you
to have some fish soup at lien Tony
Newton being is my last name and cloning
is smart so we're just going to like the
smart version of me splice that would be
an extra special treat
Taiwan is very hot yes soup is a very
hot food why did I wanna see will love
soup so much solitude hey I'm Duncan
sorry times up - no she does work on
conservation which I heard about forgot
silver mine
it's iddo sitting here that's all set up
so Edison I might not shouldn't act
gentleman at her such it suggested to
violent than me not somewhat archetype
your legacy way doesn't equal a daily
occurrences okay one finish I was called
out maybe while eating [ __ ] what kind of
fish is in this year a month yeah see on
the podium menu hey yo en hacer i wanna
tan show you knock waviness a Tom Povich
in koreguaje Dona sagessa so da da la
Tasha Wanda Tomer Devorah on - yo se
young - co-current you say to somebody
chosen al-dawa some target audience is
jo Kwon woman EPN joseph travail woman
does sit hi Tobias hi Santa Gong Hong
jinho fatigue a tofu tell I won't fire
me - you know I'm not you turn your
rhetoric over you
but no shadow at all your time why is
the fish fried and then headed
afterwards sorry it's all cheap I wanna
get a I'm dying
she says may open channel me or similar
don't cool kpop swing you know yet to
the center are you know time you hold on
straight punch answer Champa fondle tie
out again no way home huh guys cheap
would happen to it I noticed that
customers can come back with their bowls
and get more broth soma guineans I see
you got rotten hope you are not Don
transit sadena John yang terjadi Joe
starts it cheapens Allah chooses tomato
local culture
Oh Montana it's a llama taco joint I'm
Amy I put your tongue Tyler a jacket you
sure yes yes what's the plate for oh is
this your beer yes come up here Steven
look at that logo fish soup beer I'm
blown away
Cheers in Mandarin is Gombe is that
right
I'm BAE
[Music]
okay that was very unexpected Wow again
Wow
I'm thousand times very refreshing it is
give me one word Wow
so this is the marquee piece right here
should I bite into this hmm this is like
a dish that dares you to want something
else you want vegetables boom we got it
you want tofu forget about it want pork
we got it right here you want fish boom
fry it we could do it yeah when she was
listening ingredients it was just like
the NBA all-star game and here we of the
tofu next up garbage y'all ready for
this ha ha now your chairman Jiang
traders as a sheet over 200 kilometer
being the pds aqua you don't go and
watch it all right turkey rice I love
how this soup with all this stuff they
were like not you still need some turkey
rice that's right it was one thing we
learned here in Taiwan you cannot leave
a restaurant hungry they will assault
you with food in the most lovingly way
possible
mmm it's just jerking meat and fat on a
bowl of rice it's great if you weren't
an adventurous eater this would seem
like a scary bowl of food hmm
but it all just kind of blends into this
big soft hug I don't know it tastes nice
Luke it's a kind taste that's exactly
how you say it in manner in them really
good eat right good taste yeah how soon
means good eat good taste yeah what
spread the kindness once I finish this
meal it will be so long until I get to
eat this again and that makes me sad I
know this whole trip is actually just
it's the worst
yeah
[Applause]
that super was incredible
in the rainbow of soup to stew this was
somewhere in the middle and like the
stoop stupid yeah so before we get to
our next soup decided to get some treats
at the garden night market Tainan is my
favorite treats at night market it is a
peanut roll with ice cream and cilantro
what cilantro in a dessert I guess it
makes sense we put mint in desserts and
that's just Oh either green leaf think
of that
cheers Cheers Wow
I like dessert cilantro so our next soup
is actually going to be hotpot how bout
that archaeologists have found pots from
2,000 years ago that may have been used
to make an early iteration of hotpot
these were found in the unhu' Province
of China Wow old hot pot dude hop-hop
for me everybody Thanksgiving in the Lim
family we always always always eat
hotpot it would make sense that soup was
one of the oldest things humans ate yeah
just water doesn't stuff in there and
eat it tomorrow
hot pot you know where are we going we
are going to my you notice also I'll go
out to eat some beef soup as I'm talking
about beef soup get that hot pot throw
some beef in there throw some soup in
there throw some veggies in there
whatever you want what I eat excuse me
so tuna peanut why do you love hotpot so
much based on the casino lot I still
17:01 sample have $2 questions in with
attention of annuity government I wanna
go till essentially an alternative
uncommon and I sound like a yo-yo right
up your discernment a while cause I want
a song :
how often do you get the deliveries wait
time my pen same a time we so she has
its own taxes outside though sweet how
do we all know stand here no way back no
today I do okay I see we saw that it
arrived by taxi is it always come by
taxi away well my mates at the entrance
I watched it didn't so poor I am i busy
awful weather that's so cool the meat
takes a cab - everything ok no Carl
Parcells handyman it'll support all
theater now just be a theater man Nolan
Ferree my team funnyman she's gonna make
a very first few times so I persuade to
Justin go Amanda touch y'all there's
also vegetables in the dish already for
the innovator suicide sit when a key
wait that's all sides of the cow eats
hot then await our peih-gee home and i
count on the way down
yes i joke come on me for someone who's
never had hop up before how do you eat
it
touch it will not harm a nice one design
shop takeshi honda
our jin-tae color tends to year with on
potential yeah feel good like johnny be
in tiahuanaco powder
come on puta Phi equal to 13 while they
were very nervous since I don't want to
know how's it wander happy Shawn and I
had a talk on wanna watch a blow ha ha
honey hello uncle hello make while other
hop out oh yeah you also have this pork
rice it's free for all the customers
locations it be da house don't think
that that's one color I think
antioxidant no high pay pay 1 loads are
fun
JP if I could share we be in a lot of
beef on this show but this is some of
the prettiest beam I've ever seen the
color is ridiculous whole brood lon
this is one of the coolest things it's
like t snow globe and it's got the net
you know hey Cheers
hmm let's start with this one let's do
it
the total cat cheers Steven one two
Wow going in one mmm
oh no this smell is incredible Cheers oh
[Music]
that's nice bean we're just getting to
eat a really nice steak yeah with soup
and you get to eat it the second it's
done cooking
mmm I'm gonna try the same piece of meat
this time but now dip it shabu Oh
that rocks again there yeah
all right absolutely one two whoa three
like you're baptizing the meat the dip
is awesome okay that's doing it right
there's two great ways to enjoy beat you
either cook it very briefly or you cook
it a really long time this is the best
of both worlds two quick cook beef and
also the super long cook because the
soup is eight ten to twelve our feet in
beef bone soup
but enough about beef pork break what
break mm-hmm
at first this did not make sense but
it's because the beef is so precious it
breaks up the flow of so I don't just
crush my plate of beef all in one bite
like I want to well and also this bowl
of rice is bringing me more comfort than
my body pillow what I've had the same
one for over ten years it's hard to
sleep without it
[Applause]
Wow no I wash it that explains a lot
about here it's like a teddy bear we all
have that like item yeah but now mine is
in my parents attic because I stopped
sleeping with it after the age of eight
why would you give up something that's
so comfortable all right we're gonna
have the broth now we've finally reached
the soup part of the meal whoo the smell
though Cheers
ooh that is nice it's not so beefy
actually it's got like Rudy flavor
yeah apples or something this is the
best way to close out this meal yeah
it's nice a gentle landing it's like
when you have a delicious sauce you want
a piece of bread to mop it up top so us
here you just drink the sauce
hot pot that hot pot was so good okay so
we've come to Taichung for our final
soup but before we have that we're gonna
have some cold drinks that's right we're
going to 10-run one of my favorite
places in the States so I love to be
having it here in Taiwan where it's
actually from so we've got Luang tea and
a black tea boba confession time I'm not
the biggest fan of boba that's fine I
just eating while drinking I don't
isn't that what soup is soup is drinking
while eating it's completely different
don't get it twisted Cheers mmm that's
what I like
unsweetened nice iced tea that's all I
want instead of another soup fact we're
actually gonna have a boba fact all the
facts boba tea was invented in the 1980s
in Taichung
Oh some genius out here putting boba and
milky together their controversies
around who actually invented boba milk
tea
there's multiple reports of different
people so interesting we're now on our
way to goo ba me where we're going to
see chef Chen to try her beef noodle
soup the iconic dish of Taiwan we've had
it a few times off-camera so far just
for our crew meals and such and it's
usually a very inexpensive dish five or
six US dollars equivalent but today's is
going to be a little bit more deluxe
it's gonna cost around 30 US dollars
which is a lot for beef noodle soup but
it's gonna be really good
Ruba me is beef noodles in Taiwanese
island why do you think Taiwan loves
their beef noodle soup so much it's fast
and also its luxury you have a big bowl
of noodle soup and meat I never really
see restaurants can do all three good I
want to do things the best so when I do
noodles I want to find out the best
formula hui test with different flours
for almost six months I would say we
want the noodles to be authentic in the
middle but also the outside can absorb a
little bit the suit we use the Japanese
Wagyu beef shank and also we have a
condiment of smoked bone marrow and on
top of a we have some shabu shabu of the
beef shank to give two different
textures of the meat what is your
background in cooking like where did you
come from I learned in Paris I travelled
to stay sell a little bit and then I
come back I started my French restaurant
ten years ago very fine dining it was my
dream restaurant buddies integer is very
weird
I think Taiwan people they like
something casual I want to do something
smaller and now I have the bar of noodle
shop I was just trying to do something I
like it looks like very refined but I
didn't do it on purpose I just trying to
make it good and then it becomes this
way look at this that's not soup we have
tofu skin hooked in some of the beef
stock this is the radish with lemon and
olive oil
zucchini confit and goose fat some kind
of green bean and beef mushroom
deliciousness I know that a lot of
delicious stuff in front of us I cannot
wait for the soup right now but I will
be patient
roll along hold on the soup that is damn
good
greenie mean oh I did not think that was
gonna taste like that it's a smoky porky
green bean tofu skin that looks super
juicy and you know Cheers
that's the best one no this is the best
no no no no I'm done zucchini confit in
goose fat every time I eat something
green I expect it to taste like a crisp
vegetable then it tastes like a fatty
animal this is awesome Wow finally the
beef Oh ready to eat some beef in the
soup right now oh thank you know this
thing I can't believe this I can't
believe this yeah I can't believe this
this is a $30 bold soup broth Cheers
[Music]
okay I didn't think a beef tastes can be
refreshing yeah problem yeah let's do
the choice cut meat on top
Wow very flavorful beep okay geez
I literally just ate a pastrami sandwich
in one bite
yeah and the juices of the soup just
bursting out inca have some come come
come
[Music]
those are great noodles springy chewy
look at that beef Wow
holy crap I didn't think it was gonna be
that soft what yeah it's like softer
than taffy it's softer than it's
somewhere be kidding me okay let's add
the bone marrow this is like buttering
already buttered bread Wow including all
the steaks we be in this beef best beef
taste I've ever tasted the best part I
get to eat noodles the whole time it's
like usually a steak yours eating steak
pretty fun but okay noodles the whole
time yeah I've had a lot of beef roasted
before and it's never bad it's always
satisfying and comforting but this one
is like what was born in Akron Ohio
autumn to chosen wanna use a magazine
when I was 14 I don't be a great
basketball player is LeBron James oh god
damn it
every time goo ba me one of the best
soup dishes I've ever had one of the
best noodle dishes I've ever had one of
the best beef dishes I've ever had Algy
we did there before we get to our worth
it winners Andrew what was your favorite
thing that was not a soup in this
episode the craft beer at smart fish oh
I never thought I'd see a beer with a
fish soup logo was your favorite
non-supe thick beef taxi
there's not even a escort thief in the
taxi beef out the taxi okay Steven which
soup was most worth it to you
I thought smart fish soup was an event
winner when we ate there I know the beef
hop ha was gonna be my winner when we
ate there but goo ba me is my worth of
winner today so beefy just so much
thought put into it
my worth at winner goes to
smart fish Oh fish soup was crazy truly
one of the most unique dishes I've ever
eaten okay Annie boobah me what Adam
who's your worth a winner
what yeah I've never been so this is a
win today that's it for worth it Taiwan
soup we have one more episode in this
mini series coming up next Stephen what
is it chicken
[Music]
we're in Taiwan
we're back with a three-part miniseries
joining us on all of our episodes our
friend translator fellow BuzzFeed
producer in Kelantan we're seeing some
great modes of transportation some fun
games some tricks some treats and some
delights you know you know we're in
Taiwan the beautiful 101 tower and
because it's steaming which is perfect
for the first food that we're doing in
our trip dumplings a food that's often
cooked with steam great transition
today I'm worth it we're going to be
trying three dumplings at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price I am so excited to get
dumplings excited feel like we've been
talking about this episode since season
1 what are my goal of this trip is to
brush up on my Mandarin because I have
the manners cuz I'm a four-year-old
my goal is to get it to a five-year-old
bite in this trip that's a very good
goal Thank You
dumpling number one we're going to see
miss Liu in her restaurant dad taking
about Leo Josh raging ball how's that oh
good we're gonna get some $0.50
pan-fried dumplings we had it we're
ahead of price so low I'm worth it no we
haven't
that is a drastic price point you've
been making dumplings for 30 years I'm
just curious what you think makes a
perfect dumpling house it's a Kia
vehicle maybe it is cute under cites
it's harder to sing funny
young-soon what types of buns do you
serve here women to be in the top high
doses Joe types a team foul foul D type
say Jim fell in love to camp out and
which one is your favorite well thank
you Frank Joe taught whistlin Quixote
it's young fishing
that's a deal huh Timbo detect only
assume a consistent income per home okay
send us the standard way pick up in June
not me and pure if you don't publish so
we've heard that the dough of your buns
is very delicious what makes it so
special
oh man no can't I see your mouth shall
find me yo [ __ ] would ya I'm kinder kid
9 sit I'm a fast yup so it woman me I'm
cute and cute hat out your Yahoo not now
me and fast I'll quick we can wait waste
time how many should we have make it
ain't you can to stunk up good you know
you're actually in Taiwan Oh dumplings
in motor scooters ham it's a beautiful
noise so not only are we having
dumplings but we're also having soy milk
so we noticed you're actually making
your own soy milk here can tell us about
how you guys make that I'm totally out
chain can one Sun Chien Qing power
package I thought someone went to [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] more Cheers
oh jeez
I didn't know that's what soy milk
supposed to taste like kind of like a
peanut butter drink I guess how nutty it
tastes to me
ok how's the soy milk yes I really like
this I know this is really good it's
like the first time I had full fat no
yeah yeah
Adam try some soy milk yeah let's get to
the bun let's get to the buns pork
cabbage chive look at the bottom crust
it's like a little high I'm crispy
the dough is so good what was the term
for a chewy qu that an actual term yeah
this is so QQ i don't know how to
describe the weight of it but it's
pleasantly plump pleasantly plump
okay the pork butt
oh wow that's my favorite Adam you want
to thank you
you know my problem with burgers hahaha
you're playing a game of like Jenga
Tetris as you're biting into it with a
bun you're not losing anything
lastly the cabbage I love the shape of
this one it looks like a clam
this is $0.50 we just ate three dollars
of food by the way
okay this one might actually go my
favorite damn it I don't live in Taiwan
50 cents I don't even have to be hungry
it's just it would be foolish not to the
pleasure you get out of doing really
good Joe yeah oh my gosh
QQ to you I think you need to open this
in America I can give you my dress just
open up shop next to me because I need
to eat this on my way to work please
my English your house okay John okay
Johnny English whoa oh hi right so Tommy
Montoya the bowing that was a dumpling
was actually about but Belle's a
dumpling you accused my new favorite
food terminology it's a quite warm here
in Taiwan so I think before we nee have
our next dumpling we need a refreshing
treat
we're in Taiwan what kind of treat
should we have we're going to show uh
ice the Chinese name is just salivation
it's all her things you should being
soon
this looks awesome
this is one of your favorite desserts
right generally so two types of shaved
ice here at classic mango chunks on top
of milk shaved ice and then chocolate
shaved ice with whiskey it's really good
but it tastes really different one full
mango oh wow
this texture is very surprised Oh l'm
angle ain't got good in here and try
this a mango
it's like Garden of Eden mango right
here you're so sweet of course that
tastes good you drink whiskey with ice
now in chocolate chocolate works we're
getting a food that's cooked with steam
and now we're eating ice so we're just
exploring all the other states of matter
yeah make em excuse me all right cameras
back dumpling fact it's not a dumb boy
thing huh it's related to dumplings
though probably what in fact because
most foods humans eat are soft the body
and brain have learned to like the
novelty of an opposing texture like
crunch even after all that effort to
make a perfectly hue dough mm-hmm it's
still worth it to add the crunch on the
bottom back to the perfect food man all
right we're off to our next dumpling
spot we're gonna go see mr. Chen a
steamed dumpling restaurant you got
what's name of it Nihal to names and job
when do you how do you rulings in jail
but then jeong-hwan you're learning how
many dumplings do you think your
restaurant makes per day woman you can
target a survival salon Subban
along Sucher and I just sit back one day
5,000 a day and they're all made by hand
Hey on one side took beans toilet don't
you don't super-soul call me Danube and
the Chi Chi PU the Kogan 250 on San Jose
a mint wonderful cheerio and go to
change how Ron took a pee the cute
picture what makes a really great
dumpling yeah well I'd chance to catch
another one me too sorry
Pete's a sativa no straighten me out
Joseph nation the PD New York pseudo
Qaeda sham with your tongue to go to our
chats on the Peter Keuka not just a
signal when customers come here are they
only eating dumplings or they ordering
other things as well oh my goodness it's
adventure what do you hate Cal Tech
shell Texas be baby you ain't shelter
paid it's a sitcom government doing
so we should order a few more things as
well sure you and you many times home a
boy like me young conducted Tommy John
cold wait that's right we've built that
our meal with some extra stuff here yeah
let's dumpling it up they make 5,000 of
these a literal army of dumplings on one
day feels like I'm fighting an army of
dumplings with my mallet boom did
that's incredible Wow dumplings I've had
in the past
once it's steamed it becomes loose
around the filling yeah but these are
tight and dense and still juicy inside
so juicy let's do a side dish break
I vote entry egg tobu madness yeah
destroy yo she's done good told you come
down there wake up don't go touch - no
special
don't question okay you know Wow Wow
that's not what I was gonna do oh yeah
you know what I realized yeah egg nature
is dumpling hahaha Wow
Cheers two hundred years hmm oh yeah
hold that up hold that up yeah that's
this is an egg and you can see through
it it's very jelly alright so here we
have the vegetable dumpling watching
them make these dumplings was like magic
they close their hands and when they
open it there's a dumpling it's really
like someone's doing a card trick in
front of your eyes fun fact this is
actually Incas grandmother's suggestion
a whaling yeah my grandma was the one
who recommended this place to me good
recommendation it's so good to think
about the amount of work that's put into
these dumplings and how cheap it is that
is the ultimate magic trick
that pork dumpling like a Korean spa
like a dry-cleaned shirt steamed to
perfection
our next stumbling is also going to be
steamed we're having the soup dumpling
the shell own ball that's right but
before we do that we're going to have
another time we needs dessert treat
Sunil's pineapple cake it's one of my oh
my god it's one of my favorite places
yeah so every time you come here even if
you don't buy anything they will give
this to you like a pineapple cake with
long tea that's confidence
that's like we know how good it is
because you're definitely gonna get it
yes and you will yes yeah long pineapple
cakes are really good buttery and flaky
on the outside and then you get that
really fresh pineapple sweetness and
tartness iconic iconic New York and
cheese cakes Taiwan and pineapple cake
yeah smell it mm-hmm okay I shave I got
it yeah I've never had pineapple
gamified like this she's pop the rest
well you might want to save to enjoy it
while you listen to this dumpling fact
what is fact in Mandarin oh did you say
dumpling fact Johnson the day's young
doesn't end you do language butter oh ho
Java the Dennis young jazzy does Jaden's
song now the the in 2013 and 2014
chef turned writer Christopher st.
cabbage created a soup dumpling index
measuring the thickness of the dough the
soup volume and the total weight of each
individual a long bow at 52 different
restaurants this data was then
calculated with the formula filling plus
soup divided by thickness of skin times
a hundred to assign a score representing
the quality of structural engineering
jealous now look quadratic formula was
already hard enough alright next up
we're going to a superstar soup dumpling
spot Dean type mom we're gonna meet the
boss man
mr. young it originated here in Taiwan
they right now at this very moment have
164 locations worldwide that's at this
moment as wild by tomorrow then it may
be 180 they don't know when goat eats
their truffle soup dumpling trouble have
you had it before not trouble I'm not
Bujji it's gonna walk away from the
common in Heaven's the war footing the
eto bunion from leader to the Johann now
ego journey and tightened in heaven
shall city was it always soup dumplings
they shall humble servant eight women in
versus a woman by Pyrenean you a civil
jolbon proto relevant in war put on the
guide on how do you get the soup inside
the dumpling yeah nothing to be the
people she thought in the councilman so
when it steamed it becomes liquid even
the generals back that is about to begin
such a day when the joyful songs or true
life banker and the others all Jewish
into I was a part of the changing what's
important about that pleading process in
Lord Zuko walk and type to your hands so
the type thought can jaqen a year puts
it to my house how do you maintain such
high quality around the world in sahaja
yog Hall the patch have come home movie
or chapada of Anton Chigurh mega
soo-jung machine that susume Jung
soo-jung has to feed sound to me all day
long from Sudan and go your head somehow
doesn't totally false hope
so a mega mondo face on you machine the
party in guide totally come to Vera - ah
ok click on clear how the fool can make
me cook
Tahu APA that's locally brewed and it
has a really strong flavor of fruits Oh
the logo is great it's a tiger
cheers Stephen kiss hmm good
almost slider Suzanne for the pork chow
on Belle
the most important part is the soup
inside it's sort of like the sole of the
Shaolin Bell
so we lift it up from the top we place
it at the back egg down to they're very
satisfied a little hole inside so let
the froth come out and then please take
a sip been away from me or just eat
alone
okay great I'm following instructions
Stephen mmm yes and we can add a little
bit of ginger with the sauce on top and
then you can enjoy fish a lot together
all right no wait we have a drink here
yeah I'm not good at how did you poke
that so well help oh yeah yeah that's
really good it's almost lost like the
bottom fabric Rob has like a sweetness
to it it's so good
do people ever eat it in one bite yes
they do but please be careful because
it's really hot okay somebody's gonna
apply too close to the Sun though so I
feel like I want to feel it burst in my
mouth mmm there's hot we mentioned it so
much in this video but I really have to
bring it back to the QQ even though the
dough is so thin it still is very
satisfying how do you attain that kind
of texture in like a film sheet Adam can
you try this please yeah it's really
good this is all truffle and pork shall
humble why do a truffle soup dumpling II
that is handy no yo yo hey so mu sued
house for that when you do change keys
or in gyeom my resolution about tiles so
more than dirt and and younghui okay
Hogwarts on cleanse my palate before we
get into the evening I do have to point
out the pleating on each dumpling
they're beautiful
oh yes Oh what bougie chairs are these
are awesome
okay last season we ate soup the head
truffle in and we learned that has to be
activated by heat and fat right the
truffle in a soup dumpling totally makes
sense it really says something about
this dough that even though it's still
thin you still get that QQ it's
impossibly thin a common complaint about
our show is that we always just put
truffle on stuff to make it more
expensive and we see you comments
section we see you but these are about
three US dollars for dumpling which is
expensive but for the taste of truffle
how nice this is I'd say that's worth it
show title watch doing truffle right
yeah they're not doing it wrong
Adam you want to see if they're doing it
right so we're here at raha night market
because Inka suggested that we come and
eat their stinky tofu the smell around
the stall is quite stinky but once it's
fried it is much more subdued Cheers
Steven Cheers
[Music]
oh so juicy boy crap
speaking of soup dumpling there's a soup
tofu if i thinkI tofu okay so before we
get to our worth it
winners what was your favorite thing in
this episode that was not a dumpling my
favorite thing was the fire hydrant soy
milk at the Leo josue Asian foul place
the visuals of that are just astounding
my favorite thing was getting dressed
like a scientist at Din Tai Fung central
kitchen we went through this airlock
that blew all the dust and hair off of
us and we got to see some really cool
behind-the-scenes stuff so Stephen which
dumpling was the most worth it to you at
its given price my worth it winner today
goes to the pan-fried dumplings at Leo
Joshua Jin Bao the value was incredible
there the dumplings were amazing the
cabbage bun at that location was very
nearly my worth it winner but I have to
give it to the steamed pork dumplings at
location two like my fantasy of a
dumpling is that dumpling ANCA who's
your with a winner I don't know it's so
hard I want to say too because it's my
grandma's favorite but I think it's
honestly one Danny Adam says his winners
Din Tai Fung next week
sue that's right soup again so soon you
say trust us Taiwan may be the perfect
place have soup yes so excited there's
so many soups with so many soups it's
gonna be great
so many soups
[Music]
[Music]
wertha Taiwan is back worth it
chicken another chicken yeah I know it's
a rooster which is a chickens chicken no
it's a pigeon
we're at Tynan's garden night market
we've just picked up our chicken treats
tomorrow the journey begins going to
three cities for three acts of chicken
ending in a chicken finale like you've
never seen before
[ __ ] my [ __ ] let go mmm playing a
pancake
today I'm worth it we're gonna be trying
three chicken dishes at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is most worth it at
its price so we're eating chicken but
our first chicken is actually a soup I
know we just finished a soup video but
that's just how many soups there are
here you can't escape the soup we're off
to see the Chen family at walking su or
we're gonna be trying their sesame oil
chicken what is that in Mandarin Inca my
og mild my oh jeez my og okay I'm
excited to eat some chicken
let's do it tell us about how this
business got started
a woman I pass is in my cell car honking
I thought sister - woman to turn very
equal my or T no mayo hand o YT like
that shoes anyways the pn doesn't shoot
shoes I'm guys Amir wait
Nagi she's and thumbs in food years away
Mackenzie was getting associate me with
him in with the young to hand or how to
get out karma calendar mama currency Oh
mrs. Shelton sir
how do yo yo yen the will ya the
Chungcheong sold out Jen and what we are
doing here Tycho's unit don't any my UT
Duncan now who here to know that so my
would you type - Mike so this is a
family business
what do each of you do Baba has
determines how do you have your TV my
mind is in full detail with I was it
would throw faster them kids has anyone
seen Amanda Pancho do you find it easy
working together Chi Cena pencil yeah
hello it out yeah you know each aaron
has a job without to induce attention to
detail that's me oil chicken is that
dish a classic Taiwanese dish coyote
title 10 mega mama say mucho Karachi are
Yeltsin y'all stand because our Hajj
already cool town
how do tourists what are those herbs
adding to this dish or council jargon so
we all touch a tree franchises Kikuchi
al Qaeda y'all sent in truth to Pournami
y'all just opinions in uncourteous or
the call way this looks incredible
we've got a couple additional and couch
Ramon here the Thai basil sauce the
spicy fermented bean paste and sticky
rice
alright let's taste the broth sesame oil
chicken
hmm delightful nuttiness of this SME oil
yeah super nutty's my super not this
hearty feel to it oh yeah this is
hardiest how's that ah
so incredibly juicy and tender I'm gonna
smell the thyme basil oh that's our
specialty here Wow smells like pesto
yeah
that is awesome that is like a salad
dressing to dip your soup into Adam you
gotta try the chicken in the Thai basil
what right from right oh yes
chicken even the thing I keep getting
blown away by in Taiwan I go to a meal
expecting one thing and then there's
always all this bonus stuff then this
blows my expectations out of the water
yeah I mean even when they first started
this restaurant this was a bonus dish
right that's crazy thing so there's a
lot of herbs added to this soup tastes
like an elixir it just washes away all
the pain on your body a key back
I got a soup for that tired eyes who for
that my foot hurts
throw some poop on there oh the same sue
it's very convenient Adam you want to
get some of the soup I'm pretending like
Athens over here even though he's over
there right so our next chicken location
is in Taipei the first we're gonna take
a countryside detour yes that's right
we're going to a scallion farm in Yi LAN
and we're gonna be making our old
scallion pancakes not just cooking them
when we pick them ourselves
Scalia yeah yeah it's a chicken episode
it's a soup episode and now it's a
pancake episode
what you see in front of you here is a
scallion pancake but rewind three hours
what did we do we're in this unique
Valley where you get different
temperature winds at different times of
day which create a nice perfect humidity
for growing scallions so today we've
picked a bunch of scallions clean them
up chop them cried a little bit and then
learned how to make scallion pancakes
and here we have it the spoils of our
toils mmm okay this is one of the best
things I've eaten so far you know what
time it is now time for a Taiwan food
fads the concept of shouta meaning
little eats is popular in Taiwan
basically meaning snacking throughout
the day often on street food between
meals yeah in Taiwan if you only eat
three meals in one day you're just doing
it wrong we're actually on our way to a
snack shop next pinko where we going to
- shouts idiot we're gonna see Reebok
and Julia and try their fried chicken
what makes a perfect fried chicken to
you guys even one minute at sea
yeah yes angiogenesis to trick oh god no
yo-yo Nelson
Suzie don't run then the yoga so what
makes your taiwanese fried chicken
unique same vowel sounds really you know
it's yeah I know my name is Emile solder
now machine from Yahoo I understand you
know by young we were not your men to do
audio tone Sanders ODI so we can't you
see Tommy Sheridan mm who's laughing
the next Roman challenger which I'm
quite shocked it's our boss and tom says
oh hell told you that yo my peepees who
actually go has constructor Tao Zi Luo
GaN casual which are shocked I was ok me
and telling 10 top-down solution conduct
in relevance to me I know you're getting
so hot you're not seen some cabbages it
was an alternate what do you recommend
that we drink with fried chicken
Shibuya how about you yo can the
autoloader I know Shivaji about the
kuan-yin assert or nine seconds yeah
whenever you wear total itds the
audience our faces so another capacitor
you Bob so you were just about gone so
it's our idea to see by other tied down
what this is not what I was expecting
you ready Steve I'm ready this is called
dining al fresco so we've ordered the
recommended sparkling wine apparently
you only order by the bottle here I like
that
let's go at my speed Cheers
[Music]
how awesome is this this is some Riviera
we got to eat this while it's hot let's
go whoa
oh brain grant the garlic the onion this
basil the meat inside is so soft it was
very pleasing very pleasing like brûléed
marshmallows seriously oh man while I
thought could be with a limb for
dumplings it's almost like chicken
nugget s you know it's crazy about this
we've eaten fried chicken in Minneapolis
where the restaurant thought you know
it's actually the best drink to have
with fried chicken sparkling wine and
here we are in Taiwan in this restaurant
I said the same idea I see if there's a
restaurant on either side of the world
that is doing the same thing it must be
great
do you know how I didn't why I just dual
motor make you jump oh my god this is
Eagle though I know Joe I don't get it
how do you think I'd do to lid i watch
I'm going sounds it'll work out I'm
scared to eat this because I'm scared of
how much I like it pork knuckle and
radish cake Wow
[Music]
oh man [ __ ] they're gonna push me almost
cool radish take is a platinum [ __ ]
I've eaten this like every time I go out
you know they've been running the car
suddenly they're all steamed right it's
still hot but it doesn't have that like
break through the crunch technically
that this has you can maybe liken it to
a potato pancake
that's so yeah that's crazy how should
we eat then work my goal ahead by ham
just like an apple
mm-hmm okay that looks like a doughnut
oh here's does mine does Cheers
[Music]
Oh oh my god this is like a pork
doughnut
Wow so this is actually cartilage but it
feels like that with how loosey-goosey
it is the gelatin oh the jelly of this
pork doughnut right and to wash it down
sparkling while thank goodness for this
how awesome is this
thank you this is really good yeah it's
it she's you we are at the Regent Hotel
where they serve a boba Prasant
yes you heard me right boba croissant
you got the matcha tiramisu in the milk
tea they're 21 my gut is going to our
watch up but I'm going against my gut
and go for the tiramisu I actually knew
that you're gonna pick that one because
it has gold flake on it all right I'll
go milk tea very satisfying to pick up
cheers Cheers
are you gonna bite into it yeah open it
up I'm gonna bite into it this is just
all of the textures it's nice it's like
satisfying the squishing I think there's
a word for that QQ ready for a Taiwan
food pack Steve it's our food fact
Taiwan food backed up until the 1960s
the most common Taiwanese breakfast was
rice or congee buns emerged as a popular
Taiwanese food in the 1960s when US
trade introduced wheat into the
Taiwanese diet shouldn't that fat go in
the dumpling so the hell we did well is
more about breakfast I just wanted an
excuse to talk about congee because it's
just a nice savory thing to have for
breakfast this is a very good croissant
yo I got a cake oh my this public
persona is part of a of a festival
bubbling hands region and Incas got the
crown jewel of the festival and now it's
time to take a little train ride QQ
Bernier my Bobo wrap yeah how do you
like your Bobo yeah you get like a Cobra
yeah
my name is Yoda and I like yoga not Deb
never this is a trained water bottle
that they sell on the train ticket so
once we get done with this guy we'll be
in Taichung and we'll be eating at our
final chicken locations Elmo burgers
chicken
[Music]
what kind of cuisine is the food here
Sansui gone long time attention your
team called at Hawaiian teaching in
chinga su chiang kohung hi thanks mo
Chou monitors so truly astonishing port
on the console China Nepal cha-cha
hotcha of Jaime the rapper super tight
suit each Union Station campus I will
tie the invite agenda Brazil tell us
about this dish the burgers chicken
nozzoli gender channel chatter - aha the
wholehearted open candidature party now
that's the occupation delicious bigamy
each in the computo as a younger need to
buy tea from Tesco hidden yen not just
associated shower there uhm senators the
whole town to surface on the earth Joe
dings Aisha the horrid you cannot
memeing with chapati what happened to
the beggar what I got get a tie things I
hope so Nigel was a very way was an
elusive why bake the chicken in clay it
has it to Monza young boys and men went
to John went out and were like use and
it's your language awesome
that's such a yummy density young
generally involved I own car window
you're charged with arson
Jiwan sir Taisha chancel Bank wake
transitoria shanku ah no country to
Francis repulsion tolerances oh now she
passionately tattoos anemia - pouch here
she comes
oh how do we get the chicken out from
the clay Tampa Tony the data table of
Campinas o virgin pimple
the other one is a hole the hole for
your chin so in your mirror your
conscience in she granted retreats it to
your leader
each other and Charles and charge a
child at all just sort of little feet
oncology me which one of us gets to do
it how do the hammering you do hammer
time what you just automatically assume
that you get to hammer
oh yeah you can both do it okay I can't
do hammers
yeah okay great goals oh thank you
[Music]
cheers to our final meal in Taiwan oh no
since this is our last meal in Taiwan
we're blowing it out do it I saw a
little sneak peek of what's coming
upstairs
is it gonna blow you away so this is
winter melon whoa Wow Wow
[Music]
what look at it coming out pouring on
the fish's head these look too real look
at the scales on these guys honestly
every time I've seen a koi fish
I thought they look like a tasty fish
Cheers Steven fish kiss it's a good
dumpling Oh super good this looks like
in hook when Robin Williams is imagining
the food have you seen this movie that's
all like vibrant colors
do yourself a favor go watch hook you'll
have a delightful time you'll be
reminded of this moment I'm going pink
for my hair we wanted to have just shot
all three episodes here
hmm much like the origin myth first
we're eating like an emperor and then
we're taking a journey to discover the
chicken food is all about storytelling
well I am taste but also fry telling Oh
[Music]
what yes the what let's go up there
hammer time okay all right Stephen I'm
nervous
I am scared too one two three
Wow nice looks like chocolate smells
like dirt
we just hatched our chicken dinner it is
very Dino egg like chicken Cheers
chicken Cheers oh that's good what that
is so soft some people save chickens are
boring me I would say those people
haven't had it deep-fried they complain
stuffed with pork and aromatics there's
pork in the chicken yeah Tinashe is just
adding like a sauce I think as I can
Oster soft slurry Oh
[Music]
that tastes like my mom's fried rice
whoa mmm that's weird
mom you know what this chicken is - time
capsule uh-huh
for flavor buried under dirt much like a
regular time capsule but it's also a
dish with let me dynasty is there a
letter written in there like dear diary
good yeah very soft at its core this
dish is just a plate of really nice
chicken so simple so perfect we're gonna
take it back into artistry Lambs now if
that's okay with you let's do it what is
going on yeah right now yeah dude looks
like a scene from Nightmare Before
Christmas this is too beautiful not to
share I think we should get everybody in
here and we all take a bite who wants a
swan who wants a pumpkin cheers
everybody
yes what oh my god what's a right Amin
why well why not why why not worth it
beggars chicken you know they say
beggars can't be choosers but beggars
can't be choosey
there was quite an experience Steven
before we get to our worth it winners
what was your favorite thing that wasn't
one of the highlight foods in it's worth
an episode the pork knuckle at chuja
South Sudan Oh
knuckle it was so good I contemplated
eating my own knuckles was your favorite
thing honestly the hard ass rain while
we were filming location - we had a
typhoon barely grazed us but we still
got some awesome hard rain which I love
which chicken was the most worth it to
you my worth it winner walking to sesame
oil chicken oh did that chicken had been
in the soup episode it would have won
that episode - Wow comforting exciting
inexpensive is wonderful who's your
worth a winner okay
walking Sioux totally new experience
yeah yinshuang low if you could eat with
your eyes that place would have won but
because that pork knuckle was so effing
good my were that winner must go to sue
Josh out again and go for the winner to
dance again with Reebok and Julia Annie
Adam who's your worth a winner oh the
fried chicken very good choice all right
it's a wrap on worth of Taiwan very
special thank you to the Taiwan Tourism
Bureau and helped us out tremendously
with this trip could have been here
without them
let's get out of here bye
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back welcome back Steven doing
another three Episode bursts before the
New Year rolls in you might be wondering
why we're not driving
say hi Devon Devon's up front driving
because we're picking up our special
co-star today he's an avid fan of the
show from River Forest Illinois his name
is Jackson and his visit is made
possible by make-a-wish what's up
nice to meet you hi guys there you go
yes all right Adam say hi welcome to the
car Jackson the worth out of mommy all
right whoa whoa whoa I'm the punkin
master on this show yet Thank You
Jackson for joining us on our double
cheeseburger episode today thank you for
having me you flew all the way out from
Illinois yeah the Midwest I like you
already
should we do the today on worth it you
don't do that today I'm worth it we're
having three double cheeseburgers at
three Justin see different price points
see which one is worth it the most worth
it come on a VIN price point so that's
at least six patties are you prepared
I'm hungry
good so the first place we're going to
is called burgers never-say-die we're
gonna see Sean this is a smash burger
joint I love super smash the game
ultimate you play a little mint yes
who's your main Donkey Kong okay okay
I'm an S main you're bringing all the
co-host attributes that Stephen wants in
me but I don't possess hey you watch the
NBA yes yeah that's what I'm talking
about
so your menu starts with the regular and
the regular has two patties yes why is
that
I'd like double cheeseburgers that's
what I grew up eating it also works
because it's smash bounty and tell us
what a smash burger is it's cooked on a
flattop at very high heat and you just
smash it down there so it Sears to the
griddle and the whole process probably
takes a minute or less what makes a
really good burger
it's so subjective like personally for
me I like burgers cooked on the griddle
what is the griddle add you get flavor
that's been there at the seasoning from
the food items other than burgers what
drew you to making burgers specifically
my wife and I we were always really into
burgers and got into the food scene in
Bell Lane bringing together all the
burgers we ate I thought oh I want to
try making this burger myself I started
in my backyard with no intention of
opening restaurant for a couple weeks of
just begging people to come and try the
burger friends co-workers whoever then
some people approached me asking me if I
wanted to open a restaurant and I throw
my whole life I usually just jump in and
I thought let's give this a shot and see
what happens we have a sign right here
that says always ordered - why it's an
ode to the backyard you know people
would order one and they would regret it
and then there would be a long line or
we had sold out so he's - still doable
I recommend - for you yeah what about
you do you do - are you - I've eaten
like six in one day oh my goodness I
mean we're gonna do six probably over
the course of this day for us so why not
start with - here we go all right
Jackson take it away
Wharf it double cheaper or take one
that's perfect that's better than I
usually do take two that burgers
never-say-die I also have soft-serve ice
cream
insider pro tip you get your soft-serve
in a cup order a soda on the side and
then mix it for your own float where the
correct proportions for a float does
anybody know whole bottle it's a feel
Jackson's got classic root beer float
this is Stevens I got chocolate and a
blueberry root beer okay when I'm on the
hood
cheers cheers Cheers how do you eat this
who thought it Oh floats for some soda
on some ice cream it's like some the
parents aren't home Cheers
that's right just like what Donald they
like me to who knows yeah so these fries
are fried in beef tallow apparently this
is what McDonald's tasted like way back
in the day before they switch to a
vegetable oil staying true to their
motto we've got two burgers for each of
us except for you Jackson because this
is your first time on one of these
rodeos I don't want to do that to here
whoa it looks the way a fast-food burger
looks in a commercial but this is how it
is in real life smells great bun smell
you know did you think you'd have to
wait this long before you actually get
to take a bite can I point one more
physical attribute of this burger before
we bite into it sorry Jackson look at
the way it it's like a lattice yeah yeah
yeah crispy very crispy but you can
almost see through the meat like a
spider's web Cheers
mmm crunchy - it's really going G yeah
it's the essence of burger nothing extra
there's not like strange sauces or
condiments oh man this might be the best
burger I've ever oh man
like truly what do you pee with that yes
whoa everyone next burger here we go
you'd definitely be satisfied by one of
these but you're gonna want to I do
agree order two Oh what am i doing with
my life now I'm only slightly lactose
intolerant so low levels of cheese
that's fine are you like as intolerant
at all
no you're a lucky person oh we had ice
cream - what am i doing Jackson what do
you think about the part of the show
where Adam heats thanks for the lunch
bites
twice what a cheeseburger that was
insane
Oh twins who's Sympatico so before our
next double cheeseburger we're actually
gonna get another double cheeseburger
we're going to this French restaurant in
West Hollywood called Tess I saw an
Instagram that for national burger day
they made we're gonna call it a special
desert burger we reached out in the
pastry chef Sally so kindly agreed to
remake it but double this time this
might be the most visually appealing
burger of the day
close your eyes okay man this is gonna
blow you away
three two one reveal oh it's very
realistic dude is that a strawberry yes
yes to macarons chocolate ganache mango
passionfruit cheese strawberry slices
shiso leaf in a raspberry jelly for the
ketchup Wow if you did not tell me that
was dessert I would not have guessed it
cheers Cheers how to eat this hmm
actually really good mutes chocolate and
fruit what's not to like it's sweet and
bitter at the same time that's the NA
tasting notes coming off a Jack Sammons
this isn't your first time is there are
we tired today you can have that do you
know what time it is now yes oh that
time that's right double cheeseburger
fact double cheeseburger fact one minute
bob's big boy is credited with selling
the first double cheeseburger in 1937
the chains original name was Bob's
pantry but after the double cheeseburger
dubbed the big boy was invented the
restaurant changed its name to boast its
famous burger the double cheeseburger
became so famous they changed their
restaurant name whoa we'd probably be
called Adams silent fight no Adam's big
fight Adam's big buddy yes
we're next double cheeseburger we're on
our way to see Fredrick and Max at
Burger Ward's in Highland Park similar
to this double cheeseburger this next
double cheeseburger made without meat
I've never had a veggie cheese burger
before curve ball for the episode I'm
scared and excited scary and exciting is
a good place to be with food tell us
what kind of restaurant burger wars is
the way I think of it's kind of a
bizarro version of a traditional
fast-food restaurant you used to go
frozen garden burger Portobello this is
a opposite where everything is vegan
vegetarian except the beef burger do you
think you're more popular with
traditional beef cheeseburgers or
the vegetarian and vegan crap honestly
it's like 5050 yeah we look at it every
week how did you guys develop the recipe
for this patty everything kind of has
its role the barley for chewiness and
hash shoes give it a nice crunch we're
roasting all the eggplant slicing up the
other vegetables those get sauteed with
all the spices on the flattop cooking
barley in a rice cooker with kombu and
miso roasting nuts garbanzo beans
cashews and then it all goes into one
batch and just mixed up once it's cold
it settles and then we're balling it
like a traditional burger we roll it in
panko then we patty it out so the panko
when it's cooking gives it a kind of
crispy edge helps keep the patty from
burning on the grill - all of the work
comes at the beginning so we can push it
out really fast on average I mean our
tickets are like five to ten minutes
it's like neo fast food yeah it feels
like fast food it looks like it on the
exterior but in the kitchen we're
cooking all day
now that you've explained all this it
feels like a burger joint is the hardest
thing to do for vegetarians like why I
didn't want to tackle a burger joint you
know there's the nostalgia you know it's
the experience of a diner a fast-food
restaurant having fries and eating a
burger it was also to create something
that we didn't think really existed here
you know when we grew up there was a lot
of times we felt left out so we wanted
to make sure that everyone felt they had
a good option here so to round out our
experience we also got the tofu nuggets
and french fries lord of the fries style
lord of the fries it's a good pun if you
read love of the Flies yet
Oh God can't take you anywhere
cheers Cheers oh is it good
oh my goodness for the first time in my
life I have somebody who's also a messy
eater look at that she's crying it's got
the cheese crust cheers Cheers
brother bombs hmm good Wow
doesn't taste like punch at all tastes
like we leave it's hot cheesy juicy
meaty and yet there's no mean so when
you think man I can really go for a
burger right now does this satisfy that
feeling 100%
[Music]
you don't finish that thanks dude I'm
trying to put a little hot sauce on
there oh yeah you asked me you know what
that's really good
a nice little kick it really brightens
the flavor of the burger oh it has a
good kick to it it's good it is like I'm
like in a different universe right now
vegetarian food in this universe is the
norm just gonna feel like we're in the
twilight zone side just like transported
back in time into an alternate reality
where everybody's a vegetarian and you
know what pretty good yeah what fozzy
said Wow
that's a good bite lifeline like not
just mind-blowing life blowing life my
gosh guys I'm on Patti number 10 county
that's how many Betty's in bed before we
go to our last burger it's time for one
more burger fact double cheeseburger
fact would you like to read the FAQ
today sure the price of the Big Mac when
it debuted a scene right was 49 cents 49
cents so you're telling me I could go to
love McDonald's with two quarters and
come back with a Big Mac and a penny
yeah in the 60s when it debuted oh sorry
66 right we're on our way to Petit Pois
where we're gonna see Chef Ludo and his
double cheeseburger called the Big Mac
and what is on this big mech well it's a
French restaurant so sauce
petite wha it's a classic French
restaurant the design and the food is
very French and so you have this burger
how does that fit into that classic menu
in France we eat a lot to stay cachet
you know the party so I decided to just
do a burger like what American like you
know I look a lot burger to what makes a
really good burger burger need to be
crispy and juicy when I to a steak or
any meat that's what I want I want the
meat to be crispy it's called the Big
Mac styled after the Big Mac of course
of course
yeah cuz make in France mean guys of to
partner John and V and well as we make
French food is what about the sauce so
it was very poor tone for me to have my
burger in the plate swimming in the
sauce like we neither state so I decided
to do a classic French sauce called
borderless beef stock with a lot of
shallot and had wine sauce we take like
eight hour to do then after we have aged
cheddar cheese how do you know if I were
going to put a sheet of cheese or
American cheese because I love American
cheese really love what America we don't
I can reckon trees guys come on some
people don't
when I think about French cuisine I
think fine dining or I think like kind
of fufu yeah I mean this burger is now
all coming to mind right my job as a
chef it's also to cook what people want
and it's going to mix you know American
food with French cuisine I recommend
with the burger with the [ __ ] knife
very French food is fork a knife in
French we eat our burger with a [ __ ]
knife okay guys sorry yeah we do
there it is it's really unlike any
burger I've ever seen before
look at how I plated it's in a pool of
sauce yeah it looks like a lily pad any
keep on we do the honors okay everybody
there's gonna watch you cut this in half
we're losing traction $29 cheeseburger
you're just hacking through double
stabbed through the whole thing to
secure your bite what regret saying that
I would be okay sharing the burger
I'm good cheers Cheers I'm gonna mop up
some sauce it's magical
yeah yeah boy Wow oh man that sauce
that's all I read of all the patty is so
crispy is juicy and crispy at the same
time okay if I were to go back to Burger
Lord's that wasn't everything I want in
a burger what is vegetarian this is
everything I didn't know I wanted
exactly I don't think I've had a sauce
like this before that is so rich and yet
tantalizing yes the sourness just makes
you crave more yes it does
Jason's like keep talking while I eat
the rest is this what you thought an
expensive burger would look like on
worth it
no I thought it'd look fancier most
expensive burger is like your episode
with Keith there was a lot of
ingredients like foie gras and lobster
uh-huh this one just has beef and cheese
enough sauce it's so simple you don't
need anything else
how is it I can see why you'd use a fork
and knife
so how do you feel food :
the dumb and as the time you know what
time it is double cheese with a dance
time go double cheeseburger
hey no before we get to our worth of
winners what was your favorite thing
today that wasn't a double cheeseburger
but dessert at tes oh yeah it's good you
just felt my answer my favorite thing
today that wasn't a double cheeseburger
was our coasts our Jackson oh and the
fact that I didn't have to eat alone
with Stephen
I think we'll start with you today
Stephen which double cheeseburger was
most worth it to you at its given price
burgers never-say-die the texture of the
patty was what I try to accomplish when
I add chips to my burgers crunchy crispy
juicy bone were Lynas back
you put potato chips on your
cheeseburgers yeah great double
cheeseburger I gotta say my worth that
winner just barely go through the burger
Lords oh the vegetarian double
cheeseburger that redefined what a
double cheeseburger could be next up we
got Andrew I love all of these places
burgers never-say-die probably the best
straightforward cheeseburger I've ever
had burger Lords I think that's where
I'd go if I wanted to hang out with
people am I gonna say my worth a winner
is Petit Pois
I think I am when I think about it I
start salivating I think it's the
Bordelaise sauce do you see that coming
no I'm gonna choose another fad diet
look obviously they were all great
burgers before I see my work at wonder
how did you not pick the last time
you're the high priest of food it's a
very fancy boy you know a hot dog you
picked them high-priced one steak
high-priced Wow and you actually go back
and tally the ones I think the
high-priced one though like not that off
sushi and burger okay
Jackson's knowledge of the show is
coming back to haunt us I love you too
bro
all right Jackson okay no more beating
around the bush
who is your worth it winter so the
veggie burger it was
experience for me I'm gonna start
ordering bacon burger so burger loins is
my worth it went it what are you kidding
this was a good fake out Adam whose
you're worth a winner Annie who's you're
worth a winner all right we got a good
mix here but all we know for sure is
that Andrew lost today I do not lose
this has been quite the journey thank
you for having me
no thank you for flying all the way out
here it was worth it
what show name watch out this worthy
winner decision is gonna haunt me
forever so you wanna change it I take it
back it's back for another episode of
worth it we're not just noodling around
here but we are covering noodles noodles
we've done many types of noodles in the
past pasta spaghetti ramen today we're
focusing on non Italian noodles in Los
Angeles today I'm worth it will you be
trying three delicious noodle dishes at
three drastically different price points
to find out which noodle is the most
worth it at its price okay so we're
sticking and specifically the Asian
dishes the first place we're going to
who are we going we're going to allow
sure noodle house to see Joe and Ellen
and we're having their wife's special
noodle dish sweet very very sweet like
the story is doing like it's a it is
actually a sweet story
[Music]
how did you come to start this business
together
if he comes my favorite noodle in LA it
was different than what you are used to
very different you want to keep the
original dial on my hometown Shaanxi
province west of China I'm curious how
many styles of noodle there are from
your hometown one s solvents it's more
than a thousand different styles yeah
that's a lot yeah that cuts a year north
or mower to also and my hometown won't
make a lot most the time we make it with
the lamb or beef so actually it's a very
similar like macaroni noodles knife cut
no though it's a flat under fake no
dough that's another way you order makes
stir-fry we are focusing on the wife
special noodle dish could you tell us
what is this story behind that dish
introduces just about what a woman are
sitting here
porridge hundred cars filled on sina
pona calculate on the union and the
constant battle Elena tell me who
commissioned have not survived its well
you gotta admit how the hot shirt hold
on here the a which is what I can't hear
not sure how I'm looking on the Ludo is
called a hollow style and long and thin
note of the machine push it to the
positive reactivates so it's very very
fresh where they only take two or three
minutes to cook it the first assault the
beef tasting will be a little bit spicy
and the tomato with a go we just use
tomato fried with egg a little bit sour
tasty the ground pork justice I'm being
paid to waste ground pork if I'm
understanding this correctly in your
hometown it's common to eat each of
these sauces with noodles
sometimes people will combine two and
you had the idea to put all three
together yeah why was that the flavor
will be more conflict because I realize
this together and have a vegetable and
meat have a solver has a salty one Bowl
and great you guys also make dumplings
here do you have a recommendation which
one we should try no lumps you at home
I'm gonna do it with vinegar and chili
oil
sometimes your shares yeah go to the
bath together
come on yeah I have another share some
with that I don't there it is won't win
any it's a very soft way I'm very light
yeah et hasn't had one actually the most
important thing about this dumpling the
wrapper which is the same dough as the
noodles this is a lot of food this is a
fun amount
cheers Cheers
mmm delicious noodle yeah I always loved
a noodle that you can just stuff in your
face already monsters are here I see any
going like this with the headphones
tries a lot of his LARPing going on
honestly I'd never heard of tomato egg
before today this is crazy because it's
like combining all these flavors from my
childhood it's all those things it's
like whoa like you can just like that's
ratatouille I still haven't seen that
movie thousand types of noodles
so comforting very very good noodle dish
before we go to our next noodle place
known to a place called Bistro Naz that
does Beijing specialty desserts yes and
this place is recommended by our good
friend Edie you want to finish that
before we yeah this is the biggest lazy
susan I've ever seen okay
I said UT where should we get some
desserts and she said you have to go to
bistro nas why is that they have foods
from my hometown Beijing I eat here a
lot cure my homesick and their dessert
is something I grew up eating so I
figure you guys should try Wow okay so
this is how you deal is I know exactly
what I want but I want a CD what we
should eat then dunkey ro the donkey
roll yes okay do you want to start with
a donkey wrong that's not the best one
either you're wrong I'm this has to be a
roll kind of guy
[Music]
before we enjoy the rest of these
desserts let's enjoy a noodle fact no
fact or your noodle oh wow new aren't
all effects and noodle facts yeah cuz
they improve your noodle yeah no I did
that joke just now the Chinese generally
speaking don't dry their pasta but
Italians do I have never made that
distinction for a spaghetti episode we
saw spaghetti extruded but they allowed
it to dry before boiling whereas at Lau
sure it extruded straight into the water
I think it's because it's not optimized
for that al dente flavor that I get from
drying it explains so much of why I like
Chinese new those more than pasta yeah
cuz they're just squishier bushier yeah
hmm so for our next noodle stop we're
going to Cebu Gras at Dolan's Weger
cuisine we're gonna be trying there big
plate chicken before we have that we're
gonna eat the rest of these desserts
okay so the camera let's go to town
hmm what is Weger cuisine the vigor
region is located as a middle point of
the Silk Road it's influenced by the
Persian Indian Turkish and Chinese many
people as you guys have kept up and you
guys have some what dish how do you
invented this but actually this is
original vigor our chef mark ain't gonna
do all dishes today what are the
highlight dishes of whitter cuisine
in ancient time Rieger people will come
up in the desert so you make a fire and
you make that power and its shape is
like that fight polo is very traditional
raised rice means a Carol reasons
together Monta it looks like a Chinese
dumpling but bigger the dog is very thin
is stuff it with beef and onion with
spices so talking about the big plate
shake it so I imagine it's big
yes it's huge how this was a noodle
episode Andrew this is a noodle dish
right of course yeah it comes it's not
this is like very typical Chinese and
vigor fusion we fried the chicken with
the oil and pepper and
Isis cinnamon cumin star any strand
paper so this is spicy we put the potato
and we braise up another we also make
the handmade noodle knodel it should be
chewy we make the noodle with water salt
and egg whites egg whites in egg whites
in because it makes it really chewy and
it stick model this is a difference
between big chicken little bit the other
model it should be thick and white I
noticed with the big plate chicken all
the noodles are covered by the things on
top why are you trying to build this
mountain of meat on top of the noodle
because the big bitching it has so so
when you eat a knodel mix it with the
soup it's like amazing taste I've never
seen a teacup like this before
all are handmade Wow handmade yeah
flower tea this is very common in my
country this is also sort of my creation
Cheers mmm here's all the tea mmm oh
yeah Rose just in a minute here
yes cinnamon cardamom cardamom you ready
for some big plate chicken Steven big
plate chicken here we go like okay we
got we got one noodle sticking out over
here okay should we start with chickens
yeah this is big plate chicken wow that
smells good mmm comes with it linger
there we go
a noodle oh I want one of those kinds of
those that one's been sitting below that
wait around the chicken got it I got it
delicious looking right okay
here's your's
whoa the noodle itself is very dumpling
what don't we like and it's soft and
that's like you're eating a dumpling in
one noodle it really is like a soup at
the bottom I know why the spoon I think
it's because the noodle is your spoon
it's say that thank you so much see the
peppercorn here all going in oh that's
so good really okay do I do it yeah no
kissing on the tongue the heat builds a
little bit the numbing peppercorn is
there all event yeah
the addition of cinnamon is really
surprising and delightful but arrival of
Malaysian cuisine a lot of the dishes
there are literally marriages there's no
better description of this than a
marriage of dishes it's delicious I get
it I get why they say stop noodling
around cuz it takes a long time to eat a
noodle is that it sometimes when you get
out of the movie and you're like I don't
know what to say like when you finish a
good book and you just need to like take
a walk and do nothing or like one and a
half hour drive across Los Angeles all
the way to Beverly Hills because that's
where we're going next but before that
happens new fact historians believe that
Chinese noodles originated more than X
years ago what is X 1500 years ago now
double that and add a thousand four
thousand four thousand years ago I
wonder what the first shape was you've
learned that phone here and without of
that before yeah what was the first
noodle shape Oh new no shade yeah
whoa okay going across town make my boy
go south now I headed to crustacean a
landmark vietnamese-american spot we're
gonna be having ons
famous garlic noodles and on top of that
Dungeness crab the noodles are a
creation of the founder of the
restaurant lean on and she's kept the
recipe secret so they are made in a
seafood kitchen and we can go in there
we'll be speaking with chef Tony maybe
he can spill the beans on these noodles
that's okay I mean Oprah actually filmed
here and she wasn't allowed in there so
we're pretty much Oprah
I understand that your kitchen operates
somewhat in the secret somewhat yeah we
have a kitchen within the kitchen
that kitchens for family members and
people that have worked in the
restaurant for over ten years
why my boss chef Holly nan she first
started way back in the 70s in this
little deli and slowly putting Asian
flares here and there she knew she was
on to something so she wanted to keep it
within the family who have bought four
items that come from Sikh originally the
garlic noodles have been around since
it's been open she saw that everybody
loves spaghetti and like parmesan so
that was her inspiration she was just
named the mother of Asian fusion this is
the signature dish of the restaurant
Asian fusion has been looked at in a
variety of ways where I grew up it was
looking down on but you're doing Asian
fusion and it's right here in Beverly
Hills how are you able to flip the
narrative of an Asian fusion food I
think it was just something cool for
people to hate on fusion but the way I
became very comfortable that is when I
spoke with Eileen she didn't really know
what fusion was he's like I just cooking
the way I want to cook now if we're
grabbing from different regions of the
world as long as you're doing it
intelligently the end result should be
pretty tasty and so this is our last
stop in our video it's the three dollar
signs but the noodles themselves are not
really the expensive thing here right
generally if you're getting a crab
you're always getting a garlic noodle
but there are two separate items on the
menu I would say 99.9% people that get
the crab they always get a noodle to
enjoy the noodles to their best this is
not a question you have to get the crab
haha gotcha yes
whoa this smells like my fire alarm is
about to go off
look at that it feels like something you
shouldn't do at a restaurant that's nice
but I do just want to go cat meows oh
man
that's so awesome actually it makes a
lot of sense
here we go here we go ah there's the hit
of garlic
takes about two seconds one crab in the
shell and one crab picked up the stone
no in bibs no way yes this is way more
simple than I thought
right Cheers oh yeah that's really good
ha I just want to eat this whole uh-huh
it's so fluffy
squishy Luffy a little I'm gonna do a
little bit of crab who's the life breed
picked crap
[Music]
it's really good right this is my
fantasy as a kid of what a dish it
tastes like this is so close to the
buttered noodles we eat as a kid where I
add on the best version of a buttery
thing buttery crab meat pre pick crab
okay is like birds who get to eat with
it's already been chewed up for them by
their parents talking about when a mama
bird chews up food and then throws it up
into the chick wings about the idea of
having food prepared for you it's a
mother's lovely it's great now how do
you make it that's the question long
noodles a long life long day that's what
they say one thing that was your
favorite things that was not a noodle
today the noodle extruder at Lau sure
noodle house that was like a
old-fashioned manual train cart at
crustacean below the floor there's a
fish tank and there's a lot of beautiful
koi fish living down there okay Andrew
which noodle was the most worth it
skipping price I'll give a honorable
mention to the hats ear noodle from Lau
sure my were that winner is gonna go to
Dolan's Weger cuisine oh my god oh my
gosh I can't believe it we agree for
once
I love crustacean I was gonna say Lau
sure because the vast experiences you
get in one Bowl I were that winner goes
to Dolan's weird cuisine Adam who's
you're worth it winner Annie who's your
favorite noodle from today Andy tea
while we're in the neighborhood well
that does it for episode 2 and our
end-of-year miniseries come back next
week for a very crispy conclusion nASA
has soft ends oh come on Adam
all right Steven this will be our final
worth in Episode four 2019 today I'll
work that we're gonna be trying three
fried chicken sandwiches at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
and its price
I think we're experiencing at the moment
a little bit of a fried chicken sandwich
craze
we thought we'd investigate the issue
and do fried chicken sandwiches
ourselves I like what you said
investigate oh look at that fresh
asphalt the way you say words it looks
golden and delicious the way fresh fried
chicken doesn't that look delicious very
tasty
what so the first place we're heading to
is the window at American Beauty chef
Alicia is going to be showing us their
fried chicken sandwich American Beauty
is the steakhouse and during the day
they have a to-go window that does
things like burgers fries fried chicken
sandwiches obviously I like that a lot
it feels very New York I don't know what
I'm going that I just like it it's like
New York
what is the window so the window is our
daytime operation where we serve
delicious food at a very affordable
price I understand the chicken sandwich
is under six bucks it's five dollars and
fifty cents Wow that is crazy
I don't know if I'd say we're
competition with fast food but we're
trying to hit around the price point of
the regular fast food chains we're
making everything in-house an idea is to
deliver hospitality to our guests
whether they order a fried chicken
sandwich at the window or they're
ordering our steaks at night so we
butterfly the chicken so it spreads out
you pound it so it's the same thickness
around I saw that you were also scoring
the meat before you were pounding it by
scoring it we're both helping buttermilk
and the seasoning penetrate well so
we're giving a little bit more surface
space so there's a little bit more
crunchy parts then we just fry it we
have the awesome Martin's potato rolls
the jalapeno aioli which gives a little
bit more fat and some heat and then we
have this very simple slaw that gives a
little freshness just cabbage some
carrots red onion and a very simple red
wine vinaigrette is that what you would
say
makes a perfect fried chicken sandwich
is it the balance of all of those things
together for me I think it's really a
combination of it all it's an evolution
while you're eating it and as it goes it
kind of all compliments itself I think
that really makes for a better and more
enjoyable eating experience
that's our order thank you thank you oh
that smells awesome it's all right just
it was a hard hit there's something
about food in a box like this I just
love every time mm-hmm it's like the
American bento box nice you didn't catch
up with your friend I do okay hold on I
got all right let's dip right I mean
what what okay you don't dump this
ketchup on your head do it I dare you
mmm incredible fry it's crunchy like
cereal is crunchy okay let's go Stan no
time oh look at that whoa
it feels wealthier than I thought that's
that potato butter
cheers Cheers mm-hmm yeah a really good
first bite Wow
hmm looking buy it I've been feeling
everybody's gonna be good what I'm
realizing about this bun it's so soft
and fluffy that it is doing its job in
like making the fried chicken the real
star of the show so this is the why are
we having fried chicken as a sandwich
question you know cuz we've done fried
chicken before mm-hmm the bun just dials
the whole thing back into like soft and
donut territory huge I kind of like you
know what this does kind of remind me of
town I think you're gonna be mad that
you didn't think of no I think it's
gonna be lots of setting than I thought
the Peking duck bun that we had in New
York that soft squishy bun with a
delicious meat in condiment and crispy
vegetable plus the cucumber and the
sweetness you're right okay yeah yeah
American Beauty what a beautiful time in
America that's too easy for you I'm
disappointed okay so before our next
proper fried chicken sandwich we're
actually gonna have a bonus piece of
fried chicken friend of the show David
Chang has a number of fried chicken
sandwich shops called fuku they have an
off-menu mega spicy fried chicken
designed to taste better as a cold
product it's like a food pun but in the
language of flavor and temperature
that's more like an oxymoron it's like a
fun you got to be it oxymoron to eat
this
okay you know it's terrifying black
gloves that come with your food here it
is oh cool
put your gloves on this guy's walking
his dog and is just looking at three
guys black gloves oh my god it looks
upset oh it looks like mummify to me why
is it so dark Adam I wish you had that
bottle of ranch on stand behind I know
we're just different this is so bizarre
like cheers oh oh it's like cinnamon
sugary - oh oh it's bad there's pickles
that you can have alongside hey ah no I
don't like this
give me that fact okay hot cold fried
chicken fact I'm mmm well that's good an
ice slush drink
speaking of worse you say hot cold
chicken time old facts in time oh wow
the chemicals and spicy foods that make
something spicy is capsaicin capsaicin
is known to increase energy reduce
appetite increased salvation and release
endorphins ability to taste reduces in
higher temperatures above 80 degrees
Fahrenheit as well as lower temperatures
below 60 degrees Fahrenheit oh I think
this chicken might be right in the
center it's still going oh my goodness
so we're on our way downtown to pee
Kuniko we're gonna see chef koneko and
have her fried chicken sandwich it's a
spicy no it's okay thank ya
p-kun eco means picnic plus clinical so
everything is an to-go box you can eat
outside of the restaurant like a picnic
why did you choose fried chicken as the
cornerstone of the menu I grew up with
it my grandma never liked cooking so we
always go by when I came here I ate the
southern style fried chicken with big
thick crust and I loved it so I did a
hybrid light as Japanese but also
crunches normally it's a wheat flour but
we do brown rice and potato starch
that's maybe the most special part of
our fried chicken our fryer don't carry
any gluten a lot of my friends kids
there are serious allergy and they never
eaten fried chicken so and I said okay
you can come here why did you want to
offer a sandwich option for your fried
chicken I'm trying to belong here do you
ever find those in Japan I don't believe
it's a popular thing Japanese just pack
rice ball and fried chicken and pickles
and that's our picnic but a lot of
people said clinic come on like a you
live in United States like everybody
loves sandwich come up with the great
one I wanted to make that sound it's as
special as I could
we created a golden button which carries
turmeric the turmeric is like
anti-family so you can listen your
feeling of I'm eating fried chicken turn
to me sandwich is about combination the
soft bun crunchy chicken acid from the
lemon vinaigrette I wanted to have
everything in one bite I mean you say
one bite but I've seen the sandwich and
it's quite tall yeah how do I eat that
with one bite we've come for the
sandwiches but we also got a salad No
diverse I like money seaweed and
cucumber salad our cvd
from Japan and it's salt cured the
texture is not like dehydrated like
welcoming like a paper thing it's very
median satisfying I eat my salad every
day Cheers hmm Wow I'm not sure I've
ever had this type of seaweed before it
is denser in meteor pause button back to
the sandwich she gave us good advice to
smush oh look how juicy that juice is
coming out it's the hidden benefit of
the squish Cheers
[Music]
that's awesome
Wow it's a face wiper for sure it's a
very good sailor
dude the star of this fried chicken
sandwich say it on three one two three
the branch ah defend your case cuz I
think you're wrong
it's the sourness that makes you want
all the other stuff true
but come on look at this bread it's
squishy has a nice bite it's not long
apart
it's a beautiful sandwich the texture of
this stuff almost like moss like they
were looking lost and think I bet that's
tasty Valley they would be a cool
texture to eat it's like a hanging
garden it's like that plant up there I
think this makes like potentially the
perfect sandwich you got this fried
chicken that's delicious but then the
things are rounded so that you're not
feeling like a easy son easy at all
pitch fried chicken on this side right
so she's like okay what do I put on this
side to balance it out spreads miso jam
pickles a little too far oh okay
jalapeno is on this side boom like we
said some good stuff but whoa dirty move
Adam it's a dirty dirty room
or even the one that you didn't already
steal basic tricking out of I see I know
how you work
pika Nico what do you think the brat so
good I feel like a picnic before we go
to our next spot fried chicken sandwich
spec time fried chicken sandwich back
though it's not currently on the menu
for a time KFC offered the Double Down
sandwich I remember that one which
consisted of two fried chicken fillets
doubling as the bun and the filling was
bacon cheese and sauce I actually have a
very fond memory of this you actually
ate this thing I tried it it was as
amazing as it sounds really
I remember that thing that was madness
it's like just eat food guys what are
you doing
isn't it even a sandwich at that point
or are you just picking up food like if
I just pick up a steak and eat it with
my hand is that a sandwich we started
this video at a steak house mm-hmm now
we're going to a seafood restaurant oh
okay we're on our way to son-of-a-gun
where chef Greg is going to show us
their fried chicken sandwich and
probably a couple other seafood treats
is this modeled after a certain style or
like genre of seafood definitely Jon and
Vinny the owners are from Florida the
vibe of it is a Florida fish shack I
wonder why you put a fried chicken
sandwich on a menu of a seafood
restaurant well our menu is really
diverse which is like the way we like to
eat living in Los Angeles you have so
much diversity there's amazing food in
Koreatown amazing Chinese food in San
Gabriel you name it we got it here so
this is what influences our menu
we're not an Italian restaurant we're
not a French restaurant we just take
something that we're into at the time
and try to develop a dish to the tuna
dish for example exactly yeah that tuna
dish is influenced by Peruvian cuisine
first we take market avocado red onion
cilantro and some tortilla chips mix all
that together and then the tuna has been
pounded out into carpaccio so it makes
the texture of the fish really nice so
that gets wrapped around the avocado mix
and then the bottom of the bowl is
alleged a Tigre so you eat it with a
spoon and get a little bit of the tuna
avocado tortilla chips all together
Wow delightful this reminds me of our
time at Pacific Seas remember that I
don't exist in this bar as you know me
we've shared like one doughnut
wait whoa okay these are the coolest
jobs I've ever seen this is a drink you
don't have to Cheers
because how would you like this I'm
concerned because I taste no alcohol in
there but I definitely feel in here all
right Oh a stir time hmm yeah I mean you
met me
horseradish for you good yeah Cheers
Oh hmm hell yeah okay turn it on I think
Easter's are the most Disney Princess
food it's like a spoon made of an ocean
fish and so it makes me feel like I'm in
a Little Mermaid you get what I mean no
I'm not picking up what you're laying
down people are shaking their heads but
those people haven't been having
scorpion balls
whoa wildest looking thing I've ever
seen it looks like a whole brain on a
plate whoa Wow
[Music]
goddamnit that spoon oh my god that's
good look at how much avocado is in this
juice at the bottom
it's like spicy orange juice this is
more of a cocktail than the hips yeah
what up no Steven you're mad man I was
saying it tastes more like a cocktail
within the scrubs and that not you we
take a free-range chicken breast brined
overnight and some lemon and herbs
thread it with a three step breading
process seasoned flour into buttermilk
and then we make crumbs out of the flour
and the buttermilk so it gives it a
little bit of a crispy texture when we
fry the chicken and let it rest that the
juices reabsorb and and then we use a
Red Rooster aioli which is Red Rooster
hot sauce from Louisiana it's not sure
Aceh it's more like Tabasco and then we
make a slaw with market vegetables we
make some bread and butter pickles in
house here so we'll make the dressing
for the cabbage slaw from the vinegar
that comes from the pickles thank you
okay it should not at all what I
expected to see there's pickles embedded
into the slaw it's my kind of slaw have
you ever seen a more beautiful chicken
sandwich commercial perfect okay I'm
gonna split it for us you're gonna love
the feel of this but I can already tell
yeah yeah you're a big bun guy oh these
dishes are actually very similar there's
like the fattiness and the acidity yeah
fattiness acidity basic acidity fatty
this acidity fattiness acidity whoa whoa
whoa whoa you're gonna set me up like
that when i dunk hard how does that
first time mm you know you had a good
time when the sandwich is in shambles
what do you think about the the texture
of the fried crust it's not like you
want to talk about the texture of the
fried crust
Andrew yeah now there's different levels
of crunch a crunch your crunch would be
like leaves high pitch crackle then is
also lower pitch crackle like stepping
into snow I think this is more like snow
crackle the other chicken we've had is
more like leaf crackle I wants been a
change in wind and I wants been a day in
your head just like what are you
thinking
[Music]
all right Steven we do yen that only did
we have three fried chicken sandwiches
but this also concludes a three Episode
set for us the first one had buns the
last one had buns in effect it was a
sandwich of its own what was your
favorite thing in this episode that was
not a fried chicken sandwich the giant
ropes that held the hanging light bulbs
at Kiku Nikko yes we don't often get to
talk about restaurant decor I kind of
have a similar favorite thing that
wasn't a fried chicken sandwich ah the
bathroom faucets at American Beauty it
looked like a swan throwing up the water
interior all right
which fried chicken sandwich was the
most worth it at its given price why
were that winner goes through the window
at American Beauty that fried chicken
sandwich is everything I wanted on a
Martin's potato roll which is near and
dear to my heart you know often wrong on
the show but you're wrong today oh my
word that winner goes to be good to go
that fried chicken sandwich was so
special
yeah the smashing today was pretty
excellent Adam who's your worth a winner
Adam picks B Kuniko a good Pete Kuniko
my god that's gonna be it for 2019
thanks to everybody who works on this
show to make it happen most of them are
not here and thank you all for watching
I appreciate it
we'll be back if you want to suggest the
food we do check our Instagram page
Instagram comm slash BuzzFeed worth it
in the comments of this video comments
video probably reading them right now as
you're watching this I am also watching
oh yeah what do we learned about fried
chicken delicious
well fried chicken sandwiches may
continue to be eaten the world round at
least we'll know that they taste good so
[Music]
[Applause]